hey Weejun cat fun I don't know if you
guys notice but I went ahead and put
that on the building right behind you
for you Dan how crazy is it to see that
you're on an eight story billboard right
now huh I would all these people behind
my head as well in the clouds amazing
season one was absolutely sensational it
was eight can't-miss episodes I've got
to know what's the status for season two
when you go back to summer land well
there will be a season two we start
filming September 5th all these people
are in it it'd be great right this time
I really feel like season 1 was kind of
like an internal conflict with in
David's mind what is season 2 central
theme going to be what is the one with
sort of the fight with the enemy within
now the enemies without and and yet I
think I still want to try to resist this
you know every conflict assault through
warfare idea and still continue to
explore the the ideas of mental homeless
that we raised in the first season it's
not just a gimmick to get us into a
superhero show so you know I think I
think David will find himself perhaps
feeling like the same man in an insane
world supposed to be insane man
oh by the way that's going to happen
Audrey and Dan your seams together
facing off as Lenny and David we're
always so fantastic how much creative
freedom did you guys have in those
scenes because all three I understand
that you kind of just went full force of
Lenny that's not like we just read the
script and just kind of let it you know
inspire us various places yeah yeah
we'll be removed too thanks to one
sequence yeah it was not scripted a
choice and it ended up in silhouette
yeah
kudos to this entire cast I had no idea
you were so gifted with the ability to
dance all of those dance sequences are
so amazing are we going to get more in
season two and what was your favorite
dance sequence of season one Rachel um
the Bollywood set was really great we
did a lot of rehearsal for that yeah and
yeah those things are really really fun
to film I hope we have more dancing
great musical show it is it's very
musical yeah they're probably more dance
fighting as we had with Bill and
append-only hammer this that was my
favorite was Bill bouncing with a broom
yeah my favorite was Bollywood and I
wasn't even mean I know sorry Joel dance
yeah well how awkward Joan yeah that was
kind of a damn have an interpretive yeah
the dance with a pen yeah
well when we last what's off David was
orbed away by a mysterious object Sid I
feel like you guys just can't catch a
break
what is coming up next for their
relationship and season two please tell
me she's hell-bent on bringing him back
I definitely think they want to find him
now we want to be we want to get it we
want to get him back yeah what can you
tease about where he might be going well
Rima no divisions my
have him well uh hopefully go to college
so get nice job yeah I think he's you
know he's on a journey and and you know
now that I think we've settled is this
in his head or is this real
I think he's got to figure out you know
which side of the fight he wants to be
on and and and you know can can we all
get along or now can people who are
different get along with the people who
are normal so you know I think there's a
lot of challenges coming up for him
well we as the audience know that Davis
sad is the infamous Professor X from the
x-men comic what are the chances that we
could be getting him with you thank you
well I think we want we definitely want
to address that you know I mean it's
normal when you when you learn here
adopted to want to know who your real
family is he doesn't yet know the
identity and so I think it'll be the
process to get there explode a lot of
explaining that yeah the bad is
Professor X I think right yeah then
you're like what is the x-men for yeah
so yeah I think yeah we're on that path
definitely Dan who's your dream castle
for your dad oh god I mean I just do it
takes a lot of beating it seemed
interested when I he seemed very unaware
of the show but I mentioned that he was
my dad and they seemed pleasantly
surprised work it right yeah
steady can I be your mommy complicated
well gene I loved everything that
Melanie did in season 1 but now the
Shadow King is kind of taking ahold of
her husband where do we stand with her
in season 2 ah
you know she's continually sexually
frustrated I had no idea what happened
what would you like to see happen
well I of course would like you know
like a fabulous you know romantic
meeting of the two is given eyes the
ceiling this is your hallway sorry I
don't know you and Jemaine that's a
match made in heaven real quick before I
let you know Dan has gotta know you're
soft on something we recently saw the
behind-the-scenes featurette of duty in
the beef yes and you and that amazing
CGI suit which was still how Emma Watson
keep a straight face while you were in
that outfit she's a total pro nobody's
dealt with weird things like you know
since then she has and you're pretty hot
now thank you
you're okay on your own but no thank you
any chance you can see as we jet suite
like that come into Legion at any point
I think it would be great to spend
millions to create a motion capture suit
to then turn you into yourself how you
describe my being yeah what I'm headed a
spin again thank you guys so much ice on
your line
you